I generally and not big into eating gels
it's something that just doesn't come
naturally to me and I prefer a normal
food but with the science and scored
gels there they're a little bit thinner
and really the taste is is more natural
I think so that has been a huge help as
far as getting with nutrition during the
race I went it's hard to it's hard to
digest the whole bar so you can just
grab a few gels and just get those down
quickly and get the and get the
nutrition we need and same with the go
electrolyte mix just it tastes really
good and I prefer mixing my bottle so
something that tastes good and has the
the right nutrients we need is perfect
so that's been really great for Asian i
found a even more with with the sis
stuff because i don't like having
anything it's too too hard for my
stomach and the gels are super easy to
get down so i find them just reading
more of them while I'm writing which
keeps me better fueled
[Music]
I get to just get on with they go back
to training go back to planning get on
to the next target and focus on that I
like to focus on my writing and try not
to let anyone get too deep into my head
so i just reset look at my training
schedule and get back on that
[Music]
just trying to get into the groove as
quick as possible getting the meals
nailed down getting the bed the right
time and eliminate sleep the first
couple nights not over sleeping yeah the
sooner I can into the groove the better
[Music]
nutrition is a big thing using the rico
SI its recovery mix just to kind of
cover your bases nutrition-wise eating a
good bit of carbs i like to do a lot of
physical stuff to help myself recover
stretching is a big part of it really
flushing out them the legs doing a good
stretch I've recently been just walking
more I think that's a good way to
counterbalance to to riding all day is
just getting some doing some walks in
and helping flush the legs out and then
of course a massage and foam rolling is
a kind of a final step to that series of
recovery things to just sort of set you
off right for the for rest of day
[Music]
normally immediately after a hard ride
erase all first thing I'm thinking of is
food so i'll get a sis rego in and maybe
either depending on how hungry i might
go try to take a shower first or maybe
just like go on get some rice some beans
and some chicken make sure I refuel and
then go hop in the shower start
stretching start thinking about making
some more food
[Music]
you're staying healthy what one I think
it starts in the offseason worse kind of
I think being around a lot of other
people actually helps in the offseason
so you build up your immune system and
then just when I'm once you're in season
just really stay on top of your wrath
Stan tacos keeping hands clean when
you're traveling and sometimes i like my
ID in the vitamin C supplement yeah so
it's booked all day wake up around eight
o'clock drink about a liter of water go
for a short walk while I drink that do a
little strengthening workout just to
sort of warm up the legs then I'll have
breakfast which for me is usually
oatmeal with some octopus peanut butter
and raisins in there and have a coffee
of course because all of a string coffee
here the ride starts about 10 and that
can be anywhere from 1 hour easy up 24
hours after your arrive we do lunch
which is typically a sandwich and a
salad and some carbs in there just
depends on how long the ride is after
that we'll do stretching massage and
then pretty much lay low until until
dinner time and go eat dinner with
everybody just kind of relax and relax
until until we go to sleep for them
around ten o'clock
you